il fait encore nuit noire quand judith
monde dans l'ambulance
la jeune femme de 31 ans à des
contractions elle est sur le point
d'accoucher
judith a fait appel à wheels for life en
français des roues pour la vie un
transport d'urgence gratuit pour les
femmes enceintes pendant les heures de
couvre feu car depuis mars dernier les
autorités kényanes ont mis en place un
couvre-feu obligatoire du crépuscule
jusqu'à l'aube pour limiter la
propagation de covile 19
conséquence directe de cette mesure la
hausse du nombre de femmes et de bébés
mourant lors de l'accouchement
les patientes ne pouvant plus se rendre
à l'hôpital en pleine nuit sont
contraintes d'accoucher à la maison dans
de mauvaises conditions d'hygiène
d'autres tentent malgré tout de
rejoindre l'hôpital au risque d'être
victime de violences policières
sans ce service jeunes auraient obtenu
aucune aide
la police est toujours dehors pendant
les heures de couvre-feu et j'avais peur
qu'elle m'a grèce il suffit désormais
aux patientes de composer le 1196 pour
être transporté en ambulance vers un
établissement médical une initiative du
ministère de la santé en collaboration
avec les médecins locaux comme jemima
elle venait le matin soit parce que leur
bébé était mort pendant la nuit
soit parce qu'elle avait perdu les eaux
soit parce que l'utérus s'était ouvert
pendant le travail soit parce qu'elle
avait eu des déchirures très importante
et lorsque j'ai appris qu'une femme
était décédée pendant le travail
j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque chose à
faire depuis la mise en place de ce
service plus de dix mille appels ont
déjà été traitées et près de 900 femmes
ont été transportées à l'hôpital pour un
accouchement digne de ce nom